She's one of the most talked about women in
Pakistan - Asia Bibi, pictured shortly after
she was convicted in 2010.
The Christian mother of five was sentenced
to death for alleged remarks about Islam during
a row with fellow farm workers.
They'd refused to share their water glass
with a non-Muslim.
Now free, she lives in hiding.
No longer on death row, but still in constant
fear for her life.
And this is why.
Hardline Islamists, calling for her to be
hanged.
Her acquittal in October last year triggered
a day of nationwide demonstrations.
In every corner of the country, the sons of
Islam have voiced opposition to the Supreme
Court verdict by going into the streets.
What kind of verdict is this from the Supreme
Court of an Islamic republic which is troubling
Muslims but satisfying infidels?
The protests were only called off when the
government agreed to bar Bibi from leaving
the country - pending today's verdict.
But this is a case already linked to the killings
of at least two people.
The governor of Punjab province, Salman Taseer,
seen here on the right, was assassinated by
his bodyguard in 2011 after speaking in Bibi's
defence.
Later the same year, Federal minister for
minorities Shahbaz Bhatti was killed after
calling for her release.
Today's verdict is likely to do little to
appease those who will settle for nothing
less than having
Asia
Bibi's death
sentence reinstated.